senator we've heard a lot about Senator
McCain this week what's something people
would be surprised to learn about John
McCain okay that's a good question
surprised to know I've never been
stumped before how kind he was how did
that manifest its own paying tremendous
amount of tension when you needed it the
most that he could be a handful he could
rip your head off all on and on and on
but he could be incredibly kind just by
picking up the phone making sure that
you knew he was there for you and
walking you through it holding your hand
guiding you sort out of whatever it
wilderness you were in I don't think he
gets much credit at all for that but if
you've been on the receiving end of it
you'd appreciate it what would he say if
he was calling you now look up knock
that crap you're embarrassing here I
want to thank it's a thank you thank you
yes hey you know thank you for being my
friend but you know kind of knock his
crap but sentimental yeah no I don't
think he's you know you said in the
Christmas play he was Scrooge perfect
character perfect casting it just being
yourself
do you have the do you still have the
instinct to take out your phone and call
them as people ask me what puts it like
yes I literally yesterday afternoon when
I saw something that come across the
cable networks I literally almost picked
up my phone so I don't know who in your
life that you talked to about business
matters or almost share things with
about your hopes and your dreams and you
know your business activities it was
John for me I mean I can't think of
anything I've done legislatively that
wasn't with him usually being his
wingman and that's gone and that that's
gonna be the hardest
it's just not being up pick up the phone
and saying what do we do or here's my
idea yeah I went from you it's my
parents
the people that yeah you know my dad was
a huge influence my life my mom was the
sweetest person ever noon I lost him
when I was 21 so I focused on my sister
was 13 so what's for me is to focus on
my job being the senator from South
Carolina trying to help a president
that's difficult at times to make the
right decisions and keep that McCain
approach to America alive he had the
most romantic view of our country he
believed we were destined to shape
history he did not believe it was a
burden to lead the free world he
believed it was our an opportunity and
it was our destiny and an optimistic
view about America I want to keep that
if you can't talk to him what do you
hear him saying in your head it's steady
keep pushing be careful but steady stay
involved don't give up John was on the
Forrestal his plane famous picture of
him jumping off the nose of his plane
got hit by a missile on an adjacent
plane a kind of electrical short that
shot the missile through John's plane
didn't had the largest lawful loss of
life since World War two on a naval
aircraft carrier he could have easily
gone home because he was wounded well he
went to the Oriskany joined a naval
aviation squadron had the highest losses
of a squadron in Vietnam suffered from
five and a half years could have come on
orally said no then led the effort with
John Kerry to reconcile between the two
nations that's the kind of John McCain I
loved in our respect stay in the fight
but also have a forgiving heart did you
get a chance to say goodbye to him yeah
I did this is funny
I went out when he had to surgery
intestinal surgery I didn't think I'd
see him again and he said all right boy
keep the legacy going and that that
wiped me out and so we talked but I went
out the next time we watched the man who
shot Liberty valance and trust me if you
had recorded the commentary you
have played it really late at night like
3:00 a.m. in Guam very salty very John
and then that last night you know I sat
there and just held his hand and we
talked a lot about her trips and you
know stay in the fight keep it going I
went out about three weeks ago two weeks
ago I guess and Thursday night I got
there and when I walked in he just
smiled and held my hand but really
didn't say anything and Friday was a bad
day but yeah some told me to go I was
planning to go this week and I found a
hole of my schedule says now I need to
go the one thing I learned about my
parents you know you just assumed things
are gonna be one way don't take anything
for granted I am so glad I went that
smile and holding my hand was worth
everything what did you tell him I when
you when you said goodbye to him you did
good you exceeded every expectation your
dad your grandfather had for you you did
right by your country did right by your
friends and I am better for having met
you and he just squeezed really hard if
you back in the Senate could pass some
legislation not not to honor him or his
building out what would you pass what
would you try and get past the
immigration he worried to his dying day
about getting me involved in immigration
because I'm from South Carolina the
upside yeah immigration reform pretty
small in my state in Arizona it makes a
lot of sense you know he's right there
on the border but I jumped in that
immigration fight and you know I was in
every gang he was in with Ted Kennedy
the gang of this and the gang of that
I'd like to see immigration reform done
just just to show you and do hard things
and I talked about that I am 100%
committed to repairing our broken
borders to increasing legal immigration
doing being fair to the 11 million who
are non crooks giving them a place to
stay on our terms learn our language you
know pay a fine for the crime they
committed but solving the hard problem I
want to get that done because it meant a
lot to John to fix a broken immigration
system on national security
keep that voice that the only way we can
be safe here is affect the lives of
others over there then if you know what
goes on over
it always comes back to hit you here
that America's safest when America is
displaying her values to the world let
me ask you a little bit more about your
time with with with the senator you
travel all over the world together yes
every place no one else wanted to go
yeah
you were never anywhere very long no
there was a rule you couldn't have two
mills in the same country
this man john mccain had more energy
than ten men the doctor told me you in
Cindy that he had eight times the
tolerance for pain of the average person
but he had a schedule that would
literally kill you but he was curious we
were in one country I can't remember
where it was and he read a news article
about five hundred people were killed in
a protest in the neighboring country he
says we got to go I said why does it
need to be 502 we gotta go over there
and help these people we packed our bags
and we left favorite meal what did you
it was there oh it's easy peanut butter
and jelly sandwich that was lunch supper
was grilled cheese and tomato soup
simple man but we went to Afghanistan
Iraq about 45 times that I can remember
now why did we go he says you can't
learn it sorry you can't learn a thing
here you got to go where they're at you
cut through the BS the soldier will tell
you the truth you just got to give him a
chance to tell you the truth we were on
the ground in Iraq we could see that it
wasn't working it wasn't a few dead
Enders he told President Bush this is
not working John turned out to be right
he stood behind the surge when nobody
else would cause he believed it would
work Afghanistan he understood that if
you send in troops and announce their
departure at the same time it's not
going to work out he told President
Obama if you leave Iraq you'll regret it
I am gonna try to be that voice to
President Trump and it's up to him to
listen but he taught me one thing if you
want to learn about the world you have
to go see it if you want to understand
the war you have to go where it is those
naturalization ceremonies on July 4th
you would yeah I say so this is the
story about John did I remember above
all else we were fifth in a four-person
race running for president in 2007 he'd
been the front-runner lousy front-runner
ran out of money the trait Straight Talk
Express had no wheels thinking about
dropping out written off or politically
dead Petraeus invites John and myself to
come to speak to the troops in July of
2007 just when the surge was starting
everybody had written off a rocket SEP
General Petraeus and all those under his
command and John and myself so here's
the ceremony went Saddam's old palace as
July the fourth must be 300 degrees in
the place a couple thousand soldiers
hanging off the rafters on one side you
have about 600 people relisting in a
fight they could have easily gotten out
of at the battlefield itself then on the
other side about 300 people becoming
citizens in an expedited fashion because
they served in a war zone served in the
military you can get citizenship earlier
the front row of the citizenship group
there were two empty chairs with boots
John said what's this they got killed
the day before he got up John did
incredibly hot incredibly crowded and
gave a speech about our country and what
we were fighting for
I wanted to re-enlist and of the 2,000
soldiers every one of them got a photo
we stayed there for hours we get on the
c-130 we head back hot as hell and he
says if they're not gonna quit I'm not
gonna quit and that changed the course
of the 2008 primary you had some and
written notes yesterday that you were
reading from on the floor of the Senate
what were you thinking about when you
were writing it I looked at his life as
an after-action report so when a
military operations over when a pilot
comes back from a mission they debrief
here's what I learned I thought about
all the things that I learned like
imperfection and honor are always in
competition and it's a struggle for
every human being on the planet to try
to honorably handle their imperfections
that success and failure are different
sides of the same coin he had both he
learned more from his failures than his
successes that fighting and forgiving
and healing all worked together this is
the man that could have left the war but
stayed a man that opened up peace after
the
or was over this is the man that lost
his biggest ream of all to be president
and turned around on the night of his
greatest personal defeat showed the
country how to heal his concession
speech was the single biggest
contribution I think John has made to
democracy because in developing world
democracy is new the idea of picking
your leaders is new holding them
accountable is new the idea of
transferring power peacefully is new
cannot tell you how many world leaders
have told me about the concession speech
went over to the Mideast and he said
John taught us how to lose in the
Mideast you don't get much for losing
usually killed so democracy is about the
ability to lose and survive and John's
speech that night allowed this country
country to heal it could have went the
other way what did John McCain draw out
of people he your best and if your will
if you weren't willing to give it you
didn't last long
he had a group he traveled with he drew
out your ideas the thing that I wish I
could show people is on these long trips
we'd have a lot of new senators new
members of Congress and somewhere during
the trip would all come up to John's
cabin and he would go around one by one
and say what's your take away trying to
draw out of people you know sort of make
them analyze the moment and every time
you were with John you had access to the
the best of the best there's nobody that
would not meet John McCain because he is
a rock star for America the reason so
many people throughout the world are
grieving him is because he represented
the best in our country in their eyes
and he made sure that the youngest most
junior member there got a chance to
engage so he brought out the best in you
I think he certainly brought out the
best in me and he challenged when he
challenged you you could say well at
least I'm not doing anymore and he's
done he never asked you to do something
he wouldn't do you said if we if we all
like John so much why don't we be more
like him including me what does that
mean it means that I can't drift back
into you know the easy moments of the
compromise is a good thing
aboard its is a bad thing John Ren to
the sound of the gunfire when he got
there he was ready to fight but it's
also ready to end the war what I've got
to do is always try to remember the path
least traveled is usually the right one
be patient and just stay engaged you've
named a number of things that that his
legacy calls out in you you've talked
about immigration you've talked about
going to places and reminding them that
human dignity matters yes
above them boils you've talked about how
the concession speech it could have gone
the other way he sought to bind up the
nation not try to divide people and that
compromise is a good thing a number of
people find none of those qualities in
the current president yeah I mean so the
challenge for President Trump is to be
successful compromise if you want an
immigration bill you're going to have to
compromise I think the president's
instincts on immigration are pretty good
but the people around them don't have
compromise they can't spell compromise
when it comes to immigration so if you
want to be successful you're gonna have
to do the hard work of getting your
hands dirty getting people in a room and
giving something to them because they
need something to the president can do
this he is a deal maker but the people
around him not so much John saw a
campaign finance system that was broken
and morning to fix it he believes
climate change is really just don't want
to ruin the economy and trying to fix it
so if the president wants to be
successful he's going to have to do
those things that John McCain was known
for but people would say the the real
disconnect between your effort to try to
work with the president and your
friendship with John McCain is people
say all the praise that's being heaped
on John McCain does not apply to the
president and that that is something
that Lindsey Graham should be incapable
of being ok with here's what I've
learned if you really believe country
first then it's not about you it's about
your country I am the senator from South
Carolina I am a Republican Donald Trump
I didn't vote for him I ran against him
I lost when John McCain lost Obama not
only
he concede gracefully he actually met
the man to try to help him sometimes so
sometimes not I am going to do
everything I can to help President Trump
and when he's wrong I will say so I am
not buying into the idea that to honor
John McCain you have to withdraw from
America that led by Donald Trump
I would encourage President Trump to
keep doing what he's doing on foreign
policy rebuilding the military taking
Ron to task destroying Isis you're doing
a lot of good things mr. president you
want to get an immigration bill passed
you can do it but you're gonna have to
tell some people around you that
compromise is gonna be part of the
agenda here some people it bothers it
bothers me greatly when the president
says things about John McCain it pisses
me off to no end and I let the president
know it but I don't have the luxury a
plane like he's not present I don't have
the ability to withdraw from the fight
because I'm in it now I'll tell you what
John told me help him where he can't
just don't get caught up in the BS so
John McCain has Barack Obama and George
Bush speaking at his memorial service to
people with about whom he used to have
extremely bitter feelings during these
things right and so is working with the
president more like John McCain than
people may know if he was able to work
with those two people he felt bitterly
about you're working with President
Trump seems in that same spirit well
John never felt bitter about me trying
to help the president he felt bitter
about the president the things he said
that some of the things he did that he
thought hurt the country I don't know
what time would have held they had a
dinner was sending it was good you know
president offered Scindia job to help
with human trafficking and Cindy is just
completely terrific person and stood by
John but what the president the way he's
handled that the passing of John is just
was disturbing we finally got it right I
just don't know what to tell people
other than I'm not gonna quit I am NOT
going to give up on the idea of working
with this president the best way I can
honor John McCain has helped my country
and the best way I can help my country
is to try to convince my president
to do the right thing by our men and
women in uniform to bring the country
together not tear it apart and if I fail
it won't because I didn't try did you
call a president and tell him to bring
the flag back down to half-staff no but
I call some people around him and some
of this was a bit of a miscommunication
some of it was a lost opportunity and I
want to spend this coming day he's
talking about John but I'm going right
back at it the president called me
yesterday and very quick statement no
you did right by your friends I said
well I'll see you soon we got to figure
out what to do in Syria John McCain had
it right when it came to say to Syria if
you want to take another shot at
immigration count me in if you want to
do something big in Africa I think the
time is right so the bottom line is as
long as I'm around I'm gonna try to help
the president where I can what could the
president learn from John McCain that
fighting ferociously and earning
people's respect are not inconsistent
what does that mean it means that how
you play the game does matter it's not
just about winning or losing you're
gonna win some you're gonna lose some
and you can knock somebody's head off
and John did it John was very hard on
his colleagues but the one thing he had
going for him is that he would let it go
and when you needed John the most he was
there even if at the moment he hated
your guts politically but he never
abandoned a colleague over a political
issue he realized that he was part of
this Senate family what I would tell the
president you've got a lot of people you
think are treating you unfairly fight
back
but you're gonna have to be a big man in
a big office John McCain was a big man
worthy of a big country mr. president
you need to be the big man that the
presidency requires I can ask you a
couple of news of the news news of the
day questions we've got
time again the presidents yeah Ansel is
leaving what do you think about that
think you did a terrific job heroic job
at times quite frankly if I were the
president I'd pick somebody that
understood the legislative branch
because if the Democrats take over the
house then he's going to be subpoenaed
to death and investigated to death so
you're next White House Counsel the
better outside have a good skill set
when it comes to dealing with Congress
so are you suggesting he kind of go on a
war footing with with that anticipation
in the house maybe I think you need
somebody who understands the interaction
between the presidency and the
legislative branch defending the
presidency when you should but being
able to work when you have to Chuck
Grassley said don't let him go you know
that said all my colleagues like
sessions I mean like listen I'm not
asking him to fire sessions but clearly
he doesn't like sessions you know it's
his counsel not mine I'm not going to
tell the president you got to have this
lawyer forever you got to have this you
know Attorney General forever right
we're just telling me if you're gonna
let dumb again go find somebody is
capable of dumb again cuz he did a good
job for you now I hope you understand
what's coming your way if you don't have
a very competent capable White House
Counsel you'll live to regret it some
people worry that getting rid of McGann
means fewer people around him reminding
him of the constraints of the presidency
remind him to be a big man when you
suggested then that as long as I'm
around I'll remind him of how this game
played I've been pumped into Pietschmann
of Clinton I understand the process
pretty well here's what I'll tell the
president there is no scenario where you
can end this investigation the Moller
investigation through some political
intrigue and survive that's the end of
you the only person in America that can
clear Donald Trump is mower
let me ask you is it about do you think
he'd fire Attorney General Sessions
today if he could I think he wants an
attorney general but he has a better
working relationship with and to those
in my business who say you're stuck with
Jeff Sessions I like Jeff Sessions but
yeah how smart you have to be to
understand this this is not working can
we find a new attorney general that's
competent
capable that the president would have
competence in but also pledges to
protect Muller yeah I think so
here's the question about sessions the
president's real beef with him has had
he recused himself you've said it was
okay for him to that was the right thing
to had no choice right so here's what
confuses people about your position on
sessions if sessions did the right thing
by recusing himself and that's what got
the president angry when you say well
the the the relationship is broken
people would normally expect you to say
jeff sessions did the right thing we
should praise him for doing a year ago I
said if you fired jeff sessions they'd
be holy hell to pay because jeff recused
himself Trump blew up and went kind of
crazy about it and I said wait a minute
you know Jeff had to if you fire him for
this
then it'll ruin your presidency Muller's
investigation is very mature the
problems was centered on but with
attorney general sessions are deeper
than recusal now i'm going to give you a
laundry list there's nothing unethical
here but the problems between the White
House and the President and attorney
General Sessions go well beyond the
recusal
I hope they can repair these problems
but I don't see that happening anytime
soon the Department of Justice needs a
voice that people in the White House
will listen to Department of Justice
justice needs leadership and the
president needs a cabinet and he's
competent in none of that is
inconsistent with Muller doing his job
as far as I'm concerned so you think the
president has caused outside of the
investigation to fire Jeff Sessions I
think you serve at the pleasure of the
President and I think the removing of
Jeff Sessions is is deeper than just a
recusal problem but serving at the
pleasure the president means the
president could fire you if you didn't
like your haircut
I mean truly is there but do you think
there is the race yeah I think the
immigration issue about the whole family
was poorly handled the zero tolerance
brother I don't know where that came
from and I think that sort of sort of
blindsided the president you know the
bottom line is this relationship is not
working it's not good for the Department
of Justice I have nothing against Jeff
Sessions I think he's a fine man I like
a lot of what he's done his attorney
general but he's not my attorney general
to my colleagues here what is it about
us that says you've got to be stuck with
Jeff Sessions the rest of your political
life because it may be hard for us to
find a new replacement well I think
they're saying don't get rid of him
because it's saying don't you can't do
anything poor the election but I'm not
going to tell the president you're stuck
with this cabinet person for the rest of
your life
political life because it will be hard
on me that's not a good answer
do you think there was some reporting in
the paper that his lawyers told him
don't get rid of obsessions until the
Muller report comes out that would be
probably the smart thing to do if you
want a new Attorney General the problem
with replacing the Attorney General is
to Muller investigation I don't know how
long it's going to take
I'm mr. molars listening just keep doing
what you doing you know you just do your
job be fair by the president I'm sure
you will be but for the country's sake
we need an attorney general that can
work with a White House we need somebody
that department justice can lead the
organization effectively and after the
election
if Muller's reports nowhere near being
done and the president wants to pick
somebody else the burden on the
president will be find somebody that the
that we all have confidence in except
the answer to the question will you
protect Muller being yes and if you're
willing to do those two things you might
get a new attorney general if you're not
you probably won't let me ask you about
the mauler investigation you said that
at the end of the day if there is
collusion between the Trump campaign and
the Russians that'll be it for me
anything else will be just noise yeah
but you said you have faith in Muller
so if mother finds something else and
it's not collusion but then he'll act on
it right but then that wouldn't be noise
that would be little Muller and they're
so bad question for me has always been
I've always been concerned about what
Russia did I'm very concerned about what
they're up to now what would be a
breaking point for me if there is
credible evidence that that Trump
campaign work with the Russian
intelligence services to WikiLeaks or
other organizations to benefit from the
theft of the Democratic National
Committee are Podesta's emails that
would be colluding with a foreign power
whether it's a crime or not
that is a non-starter that would in end
it all for me I don't know about its
business dealings I don't know what he
and Michael coin did but that's what I'm
focused on is there any evidence of
collusion but outside of your focus
about the about the Russians you are a
lawyer and so when the Southern District
of New York basically has the president
engaged with Michael Cohen in a plea
deal that's not nothing for somebody who
knows about the law no I mean now where
this goes I don't know but what started
molars investigation was was there any
interaction between the Trump campaign
and Russia I haven't seen any not and I
say this as a joke but it's kind of a
half of a joke to collude you got to sit
down and come up with a plan and stick
with it Trump's not good at that let me
here's I guess what I'm trying to figure
out is some people hear you say look
it's either collusion or that's it and
they think we're depends on what the
other stuff is okay because as a former
impeachment manager imagine if somebody
said yeah it's either whitewater and if
it's not about whitewater that's it no
reason to look at anything else that's a
good question I'm the one impeachment
manager that voted against impeachment
based on lying under oath about the
sexual relationship with Monica Lewinsky
in my view most people would protect
themselves and their family live by an
embarrassing event what got me was
turning the legal system upside down
every sexual harassment lawsuits about
sex hiding the evidence coaching people
to lie went to the heart and soul the
rule of law but the actual misconduct of
the President and Miss Lewinsky to me
was not I wasn't going to peach him for
that but Lindsey Graham recognizes that
an investigation may start here and
ultimately be cause for a hundred
percent so that could be possible in
that but we'll see what he finds
absolutely but you're not just saying
it's out of collusion or nothing we find
something else would it be what I'm
saying that the purpose of Muller's
investigation was collusion we'll see
what he finds but it's got to be
something worthy of removing a precedent
far before you get any interest by
Republicans to do anything you said when
you're an impeachment manager and I'm
wondering if this is still your standard
impeachment is not about punishment
impeachment is about cleansing the
office impeachment is about restoring
honor and integrity to the office does
that still feel like a stand yeah I
think so I mean nobody listened
to me 20 years ago all of a sudden I'm
right the people who are praising John
the most in 2008 called him you know
mentally unstable and his campaign was
run like George Wallace she just had to
get over all this stuff but yeah
impeachment is not about solving a crime
impeachment is about and I did say this
it's the political death penalty into
the Constitution and I thought President
Clinton did too much to undermine the
rule of law too long but it did start
about whitewater and it wound up being
about interfering in a sexual harassment
lawsuit this started about Russia we'll
see what it ends with I think one of the
things you know this you're getting
grief and people are saying well he's
working with Donald Trump and he's
changing his standard but it sounds like
you're keeping the same standard you
always yeah what I'm doing is I have no
idea what mother found so many people
want to impeach the guy before anything
happens and some people literally would
never hold him accountable my view is
let Muller do his chop John I'll tell
you when the Moller report is out I've
got one goal let mr. Muller finishes
report without political interference
and if you need a new attorney general
to make Department of Justice work more
effectively I'm willing to try to
accommodate the president there with the
understanding mr. Muller gets to
complete his job last question we're
sitting in the Russell Senate office
building should it be the John McCain
yeah I think we need a I don't know I
named the Capitol after the guy and the
John McCain DC I want to see what the
family thinks one thing struck me about
all this let's get a group share ideas
what would be best way to honor John
there's probably many ways but the
Capitol Visitor Center he hated that
place it turned out to be marvelous cost
like a billion dollars but when you wait
to go to see the Capitol you you had
this Visitor Center we learn about the
history of our country what if it's the
first thing you saw was the life of John
McCain what if it was the John McCain
Capitol Visitor Center that would be
perfect in this regard it would be an
educational moment for young people to
know that men like John McCain existed
then they'll find out about other men
and women that made this place truly
great and it would annoy the hell out of
it
so it'd be my way of getting back
Senator Graham thank you thank you